it is fun to win and it is sad to lose
but afterwards it doesn't really matter
anymore
Richard Chamberlain philosophical about
not winning an Emmy last night for his
smashing performance in Shogun and the
winner is
Daniel J Dan trivanti a winner one of
eight for a show that does poorly in the
ratings called Hill Street Blues you'll
hear more from both trivanti and
Chamberlain along with Burt Reynolds
Deborah Harry and Lana Turner as the
premiere edition of Entertainment
Tonight gets underway from Hollywood for
September 14th 1981
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Tom Holly and welcome to our
opening night the premiere edition of
Entertainment Tonight meet Margie Wallis
hi the world of entertainment the movies
Broadway Music Television all of it it
changes every day each weekday and for
an hour on the weekend from now on we'll
bring you an inside look at that world
for the past few years I've been a part
of that world as a commercial actress a
former Miss World and a talk show host
I've seen how the world of entertainment
turns and I look forward now to my new
role as an observer and to introducing
you to some very interesting people
Burt Reynolds Lana Turner Deborah Harry
of blondie and Richard Chamberlain just
a few of the people you'll meet tonight
and if you stay around for the week
you'll get to know Brooke Shields Walter
Matthau Kenny Rogers Paul Newman
Elizabeth Taylor Barry Manilow Larry
Hagman and maybe even a few big names as
long as we'll be telling about all of
them I suppose it's only fair that you
know something about us I've worked on
the inside of the so called dream
machine too as an actor in movies stage
and television I've spent the past 20
years studying this business and I look
forward to studying it now along with
you hello everybody and welcome I'm Ron
Hendren you know I've been covering the
entertainment scene sometimes against
its grain for several years now and as
tom says you'll meet a lot of stars here
but you'll also get to know the people
who work behind the scenes in Hollywood
and we'll take a look at some of the
controversies that continually stir up
this town from pressure groups to the
serious business of stars protecting
themselves against potential assassins
we'll begin a five-part report on that
subject Thursday first up though the
Emmys the stars did indeed twinkle in
Pasadena last night for the 33rd annual
Emmy Awards by now you all know that
Hill Street Blues won a record eight
Emmys the highly rated miniseries Shogun
and the comedy taxi were the other big
winners as always the Emmys were a show
unto themselves
we got a peek at how it all gets put
together and we spoke with winners and
losers alike
how do you think your chances are here
this evening Oh none I'm just here for
the ride I hope I win cause what do you
think your chances yourself are tonight
I'm thinking about dinner and I'm
thinking about the fight Wednesday night
a lot of people talk to what I think the
membership getting together without
solicitation and saying you're doing a
good job that's always lovely this is
like a family reunion and like some of
the relatives you're real close to them
and some of them you're more distant and
but they're still like this family kind
of feeling that's what I like to go the
awards show for I didn't I am Cinderella
I was very moved until I was more
nervous about accepting this anything
I've ever done in my entire life what
it's true
[Music]
one of the people thought to be a sure
winner for Best Actor was Richard
Chamberlain for Shogun but he didn't win
we spoke with Richard before the awards
about his nomination in in are those
kinds of comparisons best is almost
impossible to determine
but this artificial thing has been set
up so it's it is fun to win and it is
sad to lose but a day or two afterwards
it doesn't really matter anymore it
really matters up to and including the
presentation and afterwards it doesn't
seem to have much significance the Emmy
Awards was a slick highly polished
production but it took lots of long
hours to get that book thanks to Emmy
executive producers Gary Smith and
Dwight hem Ian we recorded some of the
madness the day before the show
[Music]
same to you surely except on rare
occasions Shogun for example television
is really not an art it's a craft and
awards for craftsmanship are good we all
need recognition newspapers have their
Pulitzers but they are not generally
handed out by the bushel basket fool nor
with the unending hoopla and fanfare
that always accompanied the Emmys
consequently the day after and even the
year after a Pulitzer means a lot while
an Emmy and a hundred and sixty-five
dollars will get you the same pair of
overpriced Gucci's someday I hope we
learn to do it differently a dozen Emmys
a year say a word it may be even without
regard to category 212 people judge to
have made extra special contributions to
television that year maybe then we could
even get in and out of the show and the
hour it ought to take
[Music]
feel like it's you know we're part
partners here if like millions of other
women you identify with that expectant
mother then you'll be excited to know
Burke wants to be a daddy
I found out why in part one of our
week-long look at Burt Reynolds the
hottest actor in Hollywood Burt Reynolds
has a new movie opening this week it's
called paternity about a man who hires a
woman to have his baby to promote the
film
Burt was recently on the backlot of
Paramount Studios shooting a special TV
commercial for the commercial 50
pregnant women were invited to screen
the film and told they would be
interviewed later what they weren't told
was that the interviewer would be Burt
Reynolds I'm surprised to see you here
well I'm glad to see you thank you now
that I've experienced in this you know
maybe I'd like to do it over again with
someone who they're doing your second
mm-hmm oh well then I mean I really I'm
talking to an experienced person right
this is how it started one day yes I go
through morning sickness for you any
[Laughter]
like it's you know we're partners here
in the movie Burt plays buddy Evans a
successful businessman who has
everything except what he wants most a
child he decides the best way to have a
baby is to find a mother through the
classifieds but that can lead to some
unusual results where what those things
on your teeth they're bracelet I know
they're braces
but you have to wear them no they're the
latest in costume jewelry of course I
have to wear them
well that's just that I don't want my
son to look like jaws - well he could
end up with your forehead what's wrong
on that for you look at those lines what
lines
looks like it's suffering from erosion
as long as we're talking about looks
your nose isn't exactly classic
has anyone ever suggested that you plant
corn in your eyebrows my brother fine
sure the end a wild life can you tell us
about buddy what kind of a person is he
he likes people he loves children
especially everybody else's and he
suddenly discovers one day that he's 44
years old and has nothing to say that
buddy Evans was here except you know a
piece of rock when he dies so he decides
that this is a very sexist attitude that
the best way to do it would be to have a
child a son of course
and that's his attitude not mine it's
interesting that Burt would do a film
like paternity because his life is
similar to a screen character buddy
Evans at 45 years old
Burt also is an unmarried businessman
who longs for children something he
finds missing in his life I've read that
you said that paternity is the story of
your life is that true no they couldn't
they wouldn't be on television it's just
that a lot of things that happen in
movie are true and in terms of me that I
would love very much to have a child and
I'm not really sure whether I'd be very
good at being husband and that's kind of
true of the sky so you're ready to be a
parent but you're not ready to be a
husband yet not at the moment I don't
know I think it's silly to ever say that
you're you're never gonna do this you're
never gonna do that because you you
constantly change your mind and people
changing mind things change your mind
women changing my Bert can keep the kids
just send me his women and Lana Turner
who hasn't given an interview in years
has ended her silence at long last in
France at the de Ville Film Festival
which ended last night the blonde
superstar made a rare public appearance
and made news by telling our robin Leach
that she'll be returning to the silver
screen 71 I've been doing plays theatre
so I've had 10 years of it and I would
like to go back to where I started
films I mean that's where I grew up
that's what ever I know I learned from
that stage work is so different so I'm
hoping that I'm able to do to find the
right stories because I refuse to do
trash
that's why I've stayed off the screen
for three and four years that they got
it done
which is why people think that you but I
had become a recluse and told that you
retired no very active woman you'll see
a lot more of Lana Turner in this
exclusive interview in the first hour
long weekend edition of Entertainment
Tonight premiers a few days from now
while Lana Turner was being honored in
France Larry Hagman was just honored in
this country the crafty old jr. of
Dallas Fame was with his mother actress
Mary Martin as he was presented with a
star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame with
his many fans around him
we spoke with Larry about his secret for
success I just like working I'm a
working actor and a journeyman actor I
believe that work breeds work the more
you work the more you work and I like
working I'm a workaholic long as I got
three or four days off a week nice work
if you can get it Bo Derek was in London
this week helping to hype the opening of
Tarzan the ape men and making plans for
her next two movies a pirate saga and a
film about Adam and Eve three guesses
which parts she'll play while Bo is
doing her best to boost the earnings of
Tarzan already one of the summer's top
hits with grosses of over thirty million
dollars some people are trying to keep
us from spending her share the estate of
Tarzan creator Edgar Rice Burroughs
which tried to stop the movie from being
made in the first place has now gone to
court to get a slice of the money PI
cheetah's relatives have yet to be heard
from one of last night's Emmy nominees
was Evita perón in which Faye Dunaway
gave a remarkable performance in the
title role they came with a document
people what if I can't reach them you
can reach now Dunaway is about to set
jaws wagging with another biography
playing Joan Crawford and Mommy Dearest
after a New York Press preview of the
new film several friends of the late
actress gathered at dinner to swap
stories about Joan and some of her
off-screen antics they all raved about
Dunaway's uncanny impersonation the
amazing way she has of making herself
look like her subject here's a sneak
peek at Mommy Dearest opening next week
I'll give you a bigger head start come
on Tina
[Music]
Debra Harry of blondie
she's a mixed bag of music and
personality now she's looking to
establish a solo career in both music
and acting while keeping ties to her
band blondie and her boyfriend Chris
Stein what do you do for relaxation I
like to read I like to dance listen to
music I like rollerskating I like
swimming one way or another Debbie Harry
is not your average American Girl as
lead singer for blondie the most popular
American new wave group debbie has
established herself as the female David
Bowie a rock chameleon changing
identities as easily as hair color for
now she settled on fire engine red and
she's looking to develop a new Debbie
Harry one removed from the image of
blondie fans wonder why the change to
red
I couldn't fairly to the rest of the
guys in the band take Blondie's identity
and then go on and do a solo project I
thought that that would have been really
rude that new solo album is called
cuckoo the look and the sound was
inspired by the work of H R Giger the
designer of the science-fiction movie
alien
[Music]
that's the latest from Debbie Harry the
glamour girl of New Wave but sometimes
that image rubs against her plain-jane
upbringing as an adopted child from
Hawthorne New Jersey back when Debbie
was in junior high she began to
experiment with makeup and strange hair
dyes until she finally settled on a
golden blonde like her idol Marilyn
Monroe who she fantasized as her real
mother identified with Marilyn and we
shared a certain kind of femininity in
the 60s Debbie mixed with the Greenwich
Village crowd her addiction to heroin
and years as a Playboy bunny are well
known with the help of Christine her
current live in love she kicked the
habit and formed blondie in 1973 soon it
was hit after hit with cart of glass one
way or another call me and the recent
release touched by her presence dear
[Music]
[Music]
but the question remains is blondie top
of the charts because of the music or
Debbie's looks you know I don't think
the image is any more blatant than a lot
of male rock singers you know I don't
think what Debbie's done on stage is
more blatantly sexual and Jagger or Rod
Stewart or what-have-you those guys go
pretty far and because they're men they
they're allowed to do it so they really
have to touch you and talk to you and
just like look in your face and look in
your eyes you know fans are just like so
have so much inside of them that they
never have a release for and you are
their release you get to express a lot
of emotions that sometimes they don't
get to express those emotions transform
Debbie into her stage personality now
she's looking to channel those emotions
in the movies she's done two features
and she's looking for more unavailable
[Music]
last season's TV holdout was Larry
Hagman of Dallas this season it's Erik
Estrada of chips
what's he won a twelve million dollar
package that's what we'll have that
story on tomorrow's edition of
Entertainment Tonight
last night on the Emmys the first lady
of TV comedy was honored with a special
tribute from the Academy she was honored
by the Academy during the first
televised Emmy Awards back in 1954 for
the best situation comedy
here's that magic moment now
[Music]
we didn't expect the witness tonight
we're awful happy we did it wouldn't be
right to call our riders up here and
give it to them with it but I wish we
could thanks very very much
we're also proud to be a part of this
industry really we are we're trying real
hard we're going to keep it up
thank you and finally Dudley Moore who
stands five two told People magazine
that the favorite song if he and
girlfriend Susan Anton she's six one is
I've got you under my chin somebody
ought to tell Dudley that joke comes up
a little short
that's Entertainment Tonight for
September 14th 1981 we're awfully glad
you joined us tomorrow we'll have more
of Burt Reynolds plus Walter Matthau and
Brooke Shields we leave you now with the
music of blondie and I good night
everybody
[Music]